the covid19 infection rate is declining
in belgium
but covid19 fatigue is growing
so many months of isolation so many
masks
for me it's like something really
oppressive
tebow who doesn't want to give his last
name despises
social distancing and defies the rule to
wear a mask in downtown brussels
if i if i enter in the shop if i go in
the metro okay
but if i work alone in the street no no
that is
really too much and tebow is hardly
alone
in his opposition michael for stratten
who represents the protest group virus
madness
says no one should have to follow
restrictions except the most vulnerable
how many people would die if we would
not take any measures at all at the
moment
we don't know in fact we have no idea
new research shows
just one in three people surveyed in the
dutch-speaking part of belgium
still supports the safety measures
that's down from more than
eighty percent in march when the
pandemic first hit here
university of ghent professor martin
fanstein who led the study
blames poor official communication for
the dramatic drop in motivation
he says it's been a wake-up call for
authorities to pay more attention to
people's state of mind
i don't think we have sufficiently been
informing people
on the consequences of their behavior
for
them to take a wise decision and now
with the first of september comes the
traditional
country in belgium a return from
holidays
back to work and school it could be a
toxic
coronavirus cocktail we're quite worried
leading belgian virologist stephen van
gupt says
experts are stealing for a potential
september surge
he nonetheless agrees people should be
given more information about actions and
consequences
and then more autonomy so people can
have some freedom
to choose what they think is appropriate
for their situation
and they can adapt their behavior but
are people so sick of restrictions by
now they won't follow them
vanguard believes most do comply
i don't obey them too strictly because
it's very difficult
but i try anyway i feel much safer
wearing it we must do it all together
but skepticism is clearly growing in
recent days
open letters have been published in
belgian media signed by hundreds of
experts including doctors scientists and
researchers
suggesting the strict measures should be
reviewed
to see if they're stopping the virus or
just the vitality of everyday life
and we are joined now by who
spokesperson dr margaret
harris she's joining us from geneva
welcome to the program and thank you so
much for joining us
how do you think fatigue from
coronavirus measures could impact
infection rates
certainly fatigue is something you do
see with
an outbreak like this and one of the
problems is
people were so fantastic about accepting
very extreme measures quite often and i
and what people think is that okay we've
done this
we did our bit we were fantastic now we
go back to normal now the problem is
normal is what got us into this into
this mess in the first place
we have to learn to dance with the virus
yes
we need to be able to resume our society
yes we need to be able to resume
our human activities but we've got to
find ways
to do it safely and so
people have to be listened to the things
they are raising their concerns do have
to be listened to and responded to
but always with that overarching idea
this virus is in our community it's
killing
way too many of us we have to learn
to live safely so then concretely what
does the who recommend because i mean we
have seen
thousands taking to the streets in
recent anti-corona protests
so we particularly recommend don't be
clustered together especially in indoor
areas so my director general referred to
the triple c's put and they're the
triple c's are things you avoid
crowded spaces closed spaces
and close contact so the close contact
is the hard one because we as humans
love to be together we are classic herd
animals we feel
safer we feel more comfortable when
we're in large groups
but this is exactly what the virus is
exploiting
so if we're going to be smart about this
we really
still need to keep the distance and try
to avoid
being close together crowded spaces
indoors particularly indoors with poor
ventilation
we have autumn about to arrive here in
europe
other parts of the northern hemisphere
talk with us a little bit about your
level of concern especially
as we head into the colds or weather
what is what is the science saying right
now
what can we potentially be bracing for
yeah so it's two things the colder
weather makes us go indoors so those
three seas i was talking about
they become more attractive as the
weather gets colder and we can already
feel the
you know the cooling of the air um the
autumn really
is arriving uh so if we're going to
spend more time indoors
we have to look at ventilation and we
have to look at how we can space
ourselves if that's not possible that's
why the face coverings are being
recommended so
there'll be a limit on the amount of
viral load that's floating around
we are seeing early signs that perhaps
there's a better chance of people not
getting as ill
if they don't get such a big dose of
virus so all these things we can do to
improve the ventilation
limit the amount of virus that's being
spread keeping the hands clean
keeping the environment clean that will
help us
beat this thing so we should all go out
and get sweaters because maybe we uh
have to keep the windows open
dr margaret harris joining us
joining us from the world health
organization thank you so much
well now another place where there is
resistance to anti-corona measures
is cameroon in west africa the
government there
has recently launched a mobile testing
and awareness campaign
but as dw's blaise a young reports
health workers are facing
a tough task because some people still
don't believe
the virus is real
the streets of cameroon have never been
empty since the beginning of the kovic
19 pandemic
social distancing doesn't apply much in
daily life here
some people like maxell a small trader
do not believe the virus exists at all
in cameroon
ironically he wears this face mask to
appear on camera
but he does not think the coronavirus
has entered the country
there's talk of coronavares cases in
cameroon but we don't really see proof
of these cases
in europe when you hear of the pandemic
you hear of hundreds of people dead from
the virus
however in cameroon we don't see that
those views are echoed by many people in
this market in yaounde
the government has sent teams of medics
across the city to remind the public
about the pandemic and to encourage them
to take free coronavirus tests but the
teams often encounter hostility and
hesitation
some people believe the pandemic is a
government's calm
one of the main challenges is that we
have to test the maximum amount of
people possible because people are
hesitant to get tested
as you have seen when we come around
some people mock us they say we are part
of a secret cult
they also say we're bringing the disease
to them so making people aware about
this pandemic is a great challenge that
we are working on
14 kilometers away the government has
set up a mobile testing center
those willing to be tested are brought
here
three days into the operation this unit
has recorded one positive case
good news for the doctors the aim is to
test
trace and treat in order to flatten the
coronavirus curve
in cameroon the brain
we have had a number of people coming in
to take the test
they all come voluntarily and as the day
pass by
the number of people who want to get
tested is going up
we are now on day three and we have
processed
about 65 people who have come in for the
coronavirus test
back in the market these health workers
say the coronavirus exists
it's not over yet put on your face mask
over and over cameron has recorded close
to 19 000 coronavirus cases
with 410 deaths is one of the worst hit
countries in africa
but master still doesn't believe in it
they simply inflate the figures in
cameroon
and we don't see what they are talking
about
or the resources to fight the pandemic
are enjoyed by the wealthy
but the poor have nothing at all
despite the challenges the awareness and
mobile testing team still plans to
extend their campaign
to other regions in cameroon they hope
people will take the message seriously
to stop the dreaded coronavirus
you